bitcoin creator satoshi nakamoto could
be unmasked at florida trial so
a lot of people are talking about the
specifically the cryptocurrency
community
um so uh uh the family of a deceased man
is suing his former business partner
over control of their partnerships
assets in this case the asset in
question
uh are uh cachet of about 1 million
bitcoins equivalent to about 64 to 70
billion dollars today belonging to
bitcoin's creator and pseudoname
satoshi nakamoto the family of the dead
man says he and his business partner
together were nakamoto and thus the
family is entitled to half the fortune
this is what a florida jury will try to
tackle the family of david clyman is
suing his former business partner 52
year old 51 year old australian
programmer living in london named craig
wright wright has been arguing since
2016 that he created bitcoin claimed
dismissed by most in bitcoin community
climbing's family argues that the two
worked on and mine bitcoin together
entitled climbing's family to a half a
million bitcoins by the way very
interesting angle to get satoshi to come
out right i actually like the angle to
force the guy to come out
you know this story is really
fascinating and you know there's so much
money involved i'm surprised somebody
hasn't been killed yet right because
this goes back to 2008
somebody is holding on to that private
key right someone has it you're thinking
maybe they're not coming out for that
reason you think that's why the person
doesn't want others to know i think this
thing could be a movie it could be a
deadline episode or a dateline episode
or something now i do know the one
person on the planet that could find the
true identity here we go of sakamoto no
komodo sakamoto yeah that's a drink
bernie sanders because he'll want that
tax money right so he can go find that
person go get the tax money out he can
shame him on twitter
aoc on the case right i believe that he
could actually find it but this really
is a fascinating story who leaves that
much money out there unless they're very
very patient right and and this whole
thing with a florida only in florida
right could you find this it's one of
those only in florida um it seems like a
stretch but the deep this this is a fast
if they had core tv i'd be watching this
trial on tv right now i really would
so i think nothing's gonna happen i
don't think i mean you interviewed craig
wright do you think he's satoshi
nakamoto i don't know i i lean towards
no but i don't know but i i there's a
lot of people in the community
there's some that say craig wright
there's a lot that say adam back there's
a lot you know there's different names
that come up on who could be satoshi
nakamoto i know who robert in the office
thinks it is cia he thinks it's the cia
thinks it's the government that's behind
it the government designed this is what
he's thinking
and the other thing i think as well with
this is robert a big thing a big thing
yeah we went to the moon in 1920
gentlemen so
it's uh it's it's robert and that's a
that's a bright guy to say something
like that not like robert's not a bright
guy no no no not at all not at all uh
the only the big thing here for me is
that the
neither one of them have found have the
keys to the to the to the wallet so
without that you're screwed the private
key yes and without that you can't even
get home exactly so so why would if
you're if if if craig wright is him and
he claims to be him why wouldn't he just
reveal it it's like one thing you have
to do to prove it and he can well bbc
did a story with him i think it was bbc
did a story with him getting him ready
to reveal the key and he was supposed
and he couldn't do it i don't know if
you've seen the video i haven't seen
that video it's if you've not seen it
it's very interesting like it's still
i'm gonna show the world that i'm the
guy and it's like oh it's not working i
forgot i you know so it's kind of a
little bit awkward exactly if you listen
to this folks who do you think
especially those you guys that follow
crypto who do you think satoshi nakamoto
is go ahead tom
you know
i think things hide in plain sight
and no one has come out to counter these
guys
and so as odd as it sounds
and
the missing key
sometimes the simplest explanations like
when big complicated crimes you have all
the talking heads talking about crimes
for weeks and weeks and weeks like the
missing girl and then the guy
found in the swamp right it ends up
being very simple it's always that guy
you know no beyonce the boyfriend it's a
simpler story than we all
weave it into being while we're
overthinking it i
i tend to lean that it's these guys
these guys are in a partnership and they
create it because it's usually the
simple answer so you do think this is
the i'm leaning this way i'm leaning
this way saying you know what this is
very plausible that these two guys
created it these two guys created the
the the you know the the secret pirate
in the back you know flying the flag
against fiat currency and you know okay
question for you what's what's their
rationale for not cashing in on any of
it
tom he's asking yes a question
it's i you know i can't that's that's
the part in this case i can't get my
head around it's like why
why wouldn't one of them take the money
and run i mean in this case though if
they were partners and craig wright
proved to have it then he'd have to pay
look there there's very interesting
things with law you sent me a story
yesterday about vanessa bryan but what
happened where she was
maybe you tell the story what happened
there well she's suing la county
sheriff's department because they took
photos of the of the crash scene when
kobe died they looked at him they
circulated them she's suing them saying
that it has cost her some serious
traumatic damage right so now the county
wants access to her records of any
psychological exams or therapy sessions
so they can see if it actually did cause
that or if she's just saying that so
that's what you're saying so so that's
the part about law
that if you file a lawsuit
the person can come and ask specific
questions to validate your point that it
affected you right and in this case
when this guy is coming out saying
satoshi is my 50 50 partner
if he doesn't come out i mean law law
could almost force the sky to come out
so he's either going to be sitting there
saying look you know i don't want to
come out and give up half of 74 billion
or he's going to come out and say it's
me
and then how is this going to change
adam back said in an interview
about
why it's not a good idea for satoshi to
come out and why it's better for the
world not to know yeah the way he
explained it was it's better to not see
the one person as an expert because
every time something happens with that
currency they're going to go to so what
do you think since you started this
what do you think since you started says
i don't think that's a good idea i think
we need to leave it alone
as just a currency without a founder to
that currency that's their view on
bitcoin i think a big thing about that
too is that it's better to not have
somebody who's behind it because then
it's truly decentralized like if it's if
it's a certain person then that's his
argument you don't know how much he owns
and if that could then totally tank the
market or not so i think a big thing
there is just a matter of having it
decentralized to where we don't know and
that's part of the mystery of of which
is a good thing because that gives it a
little bit trust it's more like almost
spiritual or religious where it's like i
believe in it i don't know who what why
but that's kind of what we're thinking i
was interviewed by natalie brunell
yesterday who's a a bitcoin expert and a
finance expert kind of like a pompliano
type of person not crypto she made it
very specific she's bitcoin uh and she's
uh uh
what do you call it a finance expert
and she had a story that went live on
twitter uh that went viral onto like a
million views or two million views on
fox business she was talking on how the
economy right now is favoring bitcoin
you saw what shamath said just a couple
days ago the fact that people were
laughing at me when bitcoin was 200 and
i told him this thing's going to go to
the roof and you guys didn't buy into it
and now it's 60 some thousand dollars he
said it's going to go to 100 000. it's
going to go to 150. it's going to go to
200 000 it's a matter of time before
that happens it's going to happen in a
year two years three years i don't know
but the argument of where they are is
making more and more and more sense
on the ethereum side what's going to
make more sense is the fact that all
nfts are being purchased through
ethereum which means those who were not
for ethereum if nft takes off that means
ethereum takes off so the biggest
question right now
for an investor if i were to ask a
question and i you know
both sides of the argument they give me
a different argument here's here's the
argument what's ethereum today what is
the word today do you know what the
numbers are now not theory i was just
popping that up i lifted my phone up
yeah what is ethereum right now in over
to coinbase and see the uh the stock uh
uh it's at four thousand three hundred
and eighteen dollars okay so ethereum is
at forty three eighteen okay and bitcoin
is at sixty thousand seven thirty two
right here's the question you gotta ask
yourself what is more likely of
happening is it more likely for ethereum
to go from forty three hundred to twelve
thousand or is it more likely for
bitcoin to go from sixty thousand to two
hundred thousand what's more likely can
i say they're equally likely exactly
right okay you're saying yeah so that's
what the bitcoin folks will say that
it's equally likely likely but the nft
folks will tell you ethereum's gonna
catch up to bitcoin that's the debate
right now between the two yeah this is
the law of small stocks right you come
into a stock at five you think you go to
15. now you just tripled your money
whereas you go into you know amazon or
apple at 250 it's got to get to 600. so
it's you know it's the law of small
stocks here it's a really good point
there because you've got you know
wearable and open c really controlling
like 80 of the nft market or something
like that i mean they are the giants in
the room and it's all ethereum and you
know with um
and what's the leading mask the uh the
leading wallet mask okay so check this
out we got 324 likes right now and we
got 95 dislikes folks if you're more
leaning towards bitcoin
tripling before ethereum put thumbs up
if you're more for ethereum tripling
before bitcoin put thumbs down i'm
curious because i
it is becoming like a religion it's so
interesting watching the bitcoin and the
ethereum community can i say something
about this story i think it is utterly
fascinating that we don't know the
creator of bitcoin because if you are
involved in that world where you are
creating a currency you're in the
finance world you're interested in
making money all right you're driven by
that and this is just sitting here no
one knows either the person's dead right
or
what could possibly be the motivation
for us not knowing who this is and what
happens when this is 740 billion or a
200 billion or something like that it's
74 billion right now if we were talking
about this story at the beginning of the
year we've been way less than that but
that's a lot of money sitting on the
table that's not going to be the first
lawsuit and i just think this is a
fascinating
mystery it's a matter of time before it
comes out
i think maybe
the maybe not so much the identity of a
single person but maybe more of how this
was created and and we'll learn that it
isn't one person possibly
by the way it's it's more people voting
for bitcoin tripling than ethereum yeah
two to one is what the numbers are
looking like right now so there's a lot
of bitcoin people than uh ethereum
people especially maybe at least on this
podcast uh uh real diaz thank you for
the 20 bucks somebody that just gave 50
dollars uh said the following which is
quite interesting he said convinced the
government created bitcoin perfect tool
for moving off the books cash also
guaranteed to have built in
totally disagree with that
tell me why because it's too hard for a
government employee to keep a secret i i
could see a oh it's not it's not a
government employee though this is like
a a
a yeah but a government employee would
know of the secret
somehow if you go if you go from the
defense budget where i mean they can't
even keep track of their money they
don't know what goes where and who has
what and who has access to what and who
knows about what so if anything in the
government it's uh some sort of military
budget that's been off the books
blacklisted that where it's been then
there's a i mean look if they're looking
to change the military some former
military member that was involved with
this would talk i think when you create
something that potentially becomes this
big enough people know about it where
someone is going to say something if
it's a government entity so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]